make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so continuing on with our coverage
of the Fanus imperative we get to the
moment you've all been waiting for the
origin of the cancer verse how did it
all start how did we get to this point I
imagine a lot of you guys would really
really want to know what's going on so
before we get into that we pick up with
the aftermath of the Galactus engine and
again this is one of the coolest things
and what really shocked me when I first
saw this was just how huge the Galactus
engine was right this idea that it
absolutely dwarfed like all the cosmic
entities in size but the funny thing
about this is that you have like nova
and you have these guys who are really
like fighting this fight and watching
this whole thing go down and in their
minds they look at the Galactus engine
and it doesn't really look like it's
doing anything where the comment of the
Silver Surfer is it's fighting all the
cosmic entities on a different plane of
existence now this is why this matters
this is one of those things that you get
into you when it comes to the cosmic
entities right but the cosmic entities
as you perceive them don't really exist
that way they do but they don't
the cosmic entities are really more
representations of concepts they don't
really have a true physical form but
when it comes to these conflicts with
these cosmic entities what they have are
what are called embodies and embodies
are basically the physical form that
cosmic entities take on that are given
to them is they go to a place called the
dimension of manifestations and this
place is ran by a guy named
anthropomorphic
an anthropomorphism a physical body now
if your thing to understand here is that
we don't really understand how time
passes and the dimension of
manifestations but basically from the
time they leave the main Marvel Universe
go to that dimension get a physical body
and come back is instantaneous right
like it happens as far as the normal
human or the normal being is concerned
in the blink of an eye right it's just
is that quick but that's what you're
basically seeing here so what you're
seeing is not really a physical fight
between the cosmic entities and the
Galactus engine so much is like a
metaphysical fighter eye kind of taking
taking place on a higher plane and
that's why the the indigent is kind of
standing there but this massive conflict
taking place because ultimately Aegis is
the first one to fall and so when she's
destroyed what you end up seeing at
least as as best as people can normally
perceive it is you see like this giant
being kind of brick its way out from
inside of her and that's kind of how
that goes down it's a little funky and
it's not what you would expect it'd be a
lot easier if it was just shooting
lasers out of his eyes and hitting
cosmic entities but that was a nature of
Dan Abnett riding right to kind of
perceive it you know destroyers as you
would normally see it and so what this
does is this goes directly into the
origin of the cancer verse itself and
what we know
doing here is picking up with Fano sand
and the rest of the guardians of the
galaxy when they arrive in the cancer
verses version of Titan this is one of
the things that's kind of cooled because
for the most part it all really kind of
seems to function in the same capacity
the difference here is that vision was
created on Titan vision was not created
on earth right so the indication here is
that Ultron never existed right because
Ultron was the one who created vision
who in turn was sent to attack the
Avengers the avengers basically swayed
vision to their side and envisioned in
the avengers defeated Ultron here it
doesn't seem to have been the case now
what we're basically given here to
envisions talking to everybody Thanos
and vision kind of come to this
realization right Thanos says only one
of two things possibly could have
happened in this universe that led to
endless life either it means life itself
uh somehow been empowered right so
people have somehow found a way to make
themselves immortal or in his vision
puts that death was killed and that's
what you end up getting here now the
funny thing about this is you kind of
have to read between the lines and you
have to read very very closely to really
understand what Dan Abbott's saying and
what's going on which is why I'm here so
one of what it up happening in this
universe wound up happening in this
universe here is that Marvel as you know
much much like this the main Marvel
Universe ended up developing cancer now
in the main Marvel Universe Marvel died
right it was a story in 1984 called the
death of Captain Marvel it was a
landmark story in Marvel Comics are a
lot of really old Captain Marvel fans
love it but but the idea was that Marvel
had essentially developed cancer and
then died from it but the idea here is
that in this event in the way that this
takes place is that unlike the main
marvel universe where Marvel simply
succumb to his cancer surrounded by all
of his superhero friends more or less
that what had happened was he had
basically been reached out to you by the
many angled one so many angled ones
contacted him and said you can live if
you kill death it's the only way to
ensure that you survive and so kind of
being corrupted by them and basically
falling falling down and kind of
becoming this guy that fell to his
darker side why because in the main
Marvel Universe it was more of a more or
less accepting at once the time came and
saying this is the natural order of
things
is the way things are supposed to go I
know it sucks guys but hey you wouldn't
some you lose some and so because of
that in this instance he didn't do that
he gave in to his really to his to his
weaker self his desire to live and so
ultimately took the hands of all the
various superheroes who were there and
then modified them in such a way to
where they became the versions that you
see now and then following that
basically empowering them they ended up
killing the avatar of death they ended
up sacrificing him and what was in a
ritual called a necropsy which basically
led to its destruction now where we're
kinda the
because the ceremony took place on
sanctuary which is the ship of Thanos
that in that universe the avatar of
death was announced as well we're not
explicitly told who it was where
somebody just told that the avatar of
death was destroyed the result here is
that with this avatar being destroyed so
too was mistress death that had kind of
a shockwave mistress death died in this
alternate reality and the result was
that nobody could die anymore but the
side effect of this and what it did is
it allowed the many angled ones to pour
into that universe and when that
happened everybody became corrupted by
the power and everybody ended up
becoming the most evil and dark versions
of themselves hence the reason why you
see them acting the way that they do and
so that's how this entire universe came
into existence is because death was
basically destroyed in an alternate
reality that was interesting and it kind
of flies in the face of conventional
wisdom because what we've seen in the
years following this story is that
mistress death can't die right so during
the incursions that collapse of the
multiverse Jonathan Hickman offenders of
New Avengers mistress death was the one
cosmic entity the beyonders couldn't
kill so long as you know people could
die and so on and so forth now the
reality is she kind of served the roles
of plot device in that story the
multiverse had to end and it was kind of
hard to destroy and kill everything in
the multiverse if nothing can die right
so it kind of made sense to keep
mistress death alive on that score but
the fact remains here that ultimately
the actions of Thanos and the guardians
of the galaxy draw the attention of
Marvel when a kind of messengers of
sorts has received in a sense that like
their team that was there has
essentially been destroyed
communications been cut off and of
course Scarlet Witch ends up sending a
team to investigate following that so
the cool thing about this and this is
one of reasons why fans love Richard
riders so much again kind of
capitalizing what we had before was it
following the frontline of the fall
right I following the destruction of
Aegis ah the fact that all these forces
are there for the most part it sent the
entire United Front into retreat more or
less everybody panicked right because
like a cosmic entity was was obliterated
now and the question being asked was is
what if a cosmic entity could be
destroyed by this Colossus engine which
chances anybody else have and so what
well they they have kind of retreated
it's not really giving up is simply the
Allied Council of war right it's coming
together and say okay what's the next
step what do we do now now there's a lot
of infighting that ends up going on
there right because Medusa is
essentially like the new ruler of the
Kree since black bolts out of commission
and basically missing following the
events of the war in realm of kings
so she's the one ruling in a stead but
she's a new ruler as far as anybody else
is concerned so the old kings don't
really see her as somebody who's
battle-hardened or experienced it don't
really have a whole lot of respect for
at the same time you've got
like blastaar who's basically like I've
achieved in more or less so if he's fine
with just pillaging and plundering
everything you have all these different
ideologies in terms of how these guys
function and ultimately where they're
all squabbling amongst themselves
Richard Reiter is the one who shows up
and says everybody shut up we got to
figure out what we're gonna do here and
it's one of the cool things because when
it comes to these kind of war councils
these kind of war chieftains more or
less that what it really comes down to
is how authoritative can you be how much
command can you respect and then like do
you have it together and that's why
Richard Ryder people who read his
character who picked up with
annihilation loved him because of the
beginning of annihilation he wasn't
really careless and reckless so much as
a guy who was just there and didn't
really understand a full gravity of how
bad things could get but then when the
entire night like the entire Nova Corps
was obliterated right he was the only
one left he had to rise to the challenge
he had to rise and become like the best
version of himself and so for people who
follow his character and what they saw
was that the character of Richard Ryder
evolving and growing ultimately what
winds up happening here is that in the
face of what's going on Richard Ryder
basically says look there's a couple of
things that I picked up with the
destruction of Aegis this kind of
telepathic energy basically resonated in
within me and gave me a kind of cosmic
awareness and let me realize that what's
going on here is that while we're
fighting on this whole front that the
the forces of Marvel himself are
basically traveling around and they're
gathering various individuals who in
some form or fashion have been touched
by death and so we have to basically
grab these guys because we have to
figure out what's going on here and what
the grand scheme of this guy Marvel is
because what's going on here is not the
end game that's not what's that's not
the main goal of what's going on and so
what you end up getting here is a kind
of coming together if not a slight bit
of a return of a group called the
annihilators now the annihilators were a
ridiculously overpowered team right it
was ridiculous how powerful they were
right you had quasar who's a cosmic
being you had beta ray bill who's
basically like this super power for a
powerful for yeah gladiator it
essentially speaks for itself
Silver Surfer and Ron and the accuser
they were the original original
annihilators and they were hugely
powerful nova bringing them together is
cool but the idea of the annihilators
was designed to be a kind of extension
of the guardians of the galaxy right in
the sense of star-lord wanted a team
following the events of annihilation and
annihilation conquest they would serve
the purpose of like protecting the
galaxy and even the universe from
various threats that were out there the
problem is that with the Guardians
themselves while they weren't
interesting and they were cool and they
were composed of some various members
they
weren't all-powerful what you need it
was a team that was insanely powerful
and so forming the annihilators did that
because what you're talking about here
are some of the most powerful beings in
the entirety of Marvel Comics by the
annihilators themselves could take on
pretty much all comers right I mean
these guys were insanely not to terms of
the abilities they possessed and so as a
result so that this team is designed for
the mission a really fer for a strike
force of going in and basically grabbing
all these individuals who have been
taken by Lord Marvel and his forces you
know to basically try to complete the
necropsy by killing what they believe to
be the avatar of death to get in get out
and and basically do what they can and
so following that what you end up doing
is jumping back to the cancerverse
itself and this is when things go awry
because with everything that's happening
here and everything going on Thanos
understands a couple things the first is
that going through with this mission to
basically undo the necropsy right to
bring death to the various forces the
cancerverse means going back to where it
all started right were the original
necropsy took place on sanctuary and
then essentially taking out Marvel or
whoever else they can by introducing
death to them but it may also be one of
those things where there's no coming
back from this right like fan OHS may
actually end up dying here if mistress
death decides to reverse her impact and
make him mortal again and so if that's
the case then what he wanted to do is
basically settle all debts that's
basically what's going on here and
because Jack's a destroyer just kind of
been muttering to himself the entire
time and expression this desire to kill
thanos which has not gone unnoticed
danos response is if there's something
you want to say then say it man like I
mean if you got something to say
bring this beef to the table we can cook
it right we can grill it we can we can
we can deal with this you know and it'll
turn out one of two ways one of us ain't
gonna walk out of here alive and I'm the
only one here who's really immortal do
what you got to do and like a fight
breaks out between the two of them now
initially you have like mantis and Cosmo
trying to step in Cosmo of course being
the Russian cosmonaut dog with telepathy
he's really really cool but they
basically try to intervene using the
telepathy or using the ability of mantas
to manipulate emotions and it doesn't
work right because their power is just
way too way to be on there right like
Drax is really able to kind of block
telepathic attacks and Thanos he's just
so powered up now so amped up that he
can't really be defeated can't really be
calmed down or controlled by any kind of
telepath out there barring you know Jean
Grey is a Phoenix force or something
like that and so where you have Drax you
basically attached as a kind of
antimatter device onto fan oohs that
what this does is it literally emits
antimatter energy right like this idea
that once once antimatter comes in
with positive matter it'll basically
wipe it out it'll cease to exist and so
when that's the case this device is
attached to Thanos Drax fulfills his
mission and his idea of killing Thanos
and keeping him dead and basically
eradicate some kills Thanos on the spot
basically destroying everybody's hopes
of being able to defeat all the forces
of the cancerverse without being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to come this
explained make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the robb fork
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]